26 February 1979.
Queen Elizabeth the Second officially opens
Dubai's first skyscraper.
It is the Sheikh Rashid Tower, later known
as the Dubai World Trade Center.
VisualPolitik community, at the time, it was
the tallest tower in the whole of the Middle
East.
The amazing thing?
That it was erected in the middle of the desert,
in a place where, as you can see, there wasn't
much of anything.
So the operation didn't seem to make much
sense.
Nevertheless, it was quite a statement of
intent.
With 39 floors and at 184 meters, that’s
over 600 feet high, this skyscraper made clear
the intentions of the new Dubai that was beginning
to take shape: to become a key center for
business in the Middle East.
That was the goal.
Today, five decades later, that dream has
come true.
Dubai has become one of the greatest examples
of transformation, development and economic
success in history.
And no, these are not just words.
These days, this emirate-city is home to the
world's tallest building, the largest shopping
mall on the planet, some of the most luxurious
hotels, one of the largest international airports,
a world-scale mega-port and nearly 400 skyscrapers.
That means that since the Dubai World Trade
Center opened, Dubai has built nearly 10 new
skyscrapers every year.
And that's not all.
Dubai also tops the list for having the most
supertall skyscrapers in the world, that is,
towers over 300 meters, or 900 feet high.
No other city comes close.
And above all, it has become a real magnet
for attracting tourists, companies and businesses
from all over the world.
And, if Dubai's history is dazzling...
Singapore's is not far behind.
This city-state is one of the richest, most
prosperous and successful metropolises in
the world.
In the last six decades and despite having
fewer than six million inhabitants, it has
gone from being a poor place to becoming an
important financial, industrial and commercial
center.
As a result, Singapore has become one of the
wealthiest and most developed countries in
the world.
In terms of GDP per capita, and excluding
microstates, the IMF ranks it as the fourth
richest country on the planet.
We are talking about an estimated GDP per
capita for 2023 of more than $90,000 dollars.
And, take note, because this city, despite
its tiny size, has one of the best-equipped
armed forces on the planet.
For example, Singapore has more fighter planes
than the air forces of countries such as Canada,
Sweden or the Netherlands.
Crazy!
Whichever way you look at it, the figures
of these two metropolises are incredible.
In fact, the Globalization and World Cities
Research Network ranks them as no less than
two of the nine most influential and economically
significant cities in the world.
They are only one step behind New York and
London, the two great world capitals.
Look at this.
And precisely for that reason, here on VisualPolitik
we have already told you in several videos
how Dubai and Singapore managed to take off
and become real economic, commercial and financial
rockets.
Basically, we are talking about two cities
that became kind of company-cities.
In fact, it is no coincidence that the airports
of these two cities rank among the busiest
worldwide.
For instance, in 2019, the last year before
the pandemic, Dubai airport moved 97.3 million
passengers and Singapore airport moved 68.3
million.
You will see that this is no accident.
As it happens, we failed to notice one of
the crucial elements of this whole process:
the conversion of the governments of these
two cities into true entrepreneurs.
And the question is,
To what extent was government entrepreneurship
important in the growth and development of
these two major economic hubs?
What exactly are we talking about when we
say that the governments of these cities were
truly entrepreneurial?
Can the model that has been so successful
in Dubai and Singapore be exported to other
less wealthy places?
VisualPolitik community, in this second video
of the series we are preparing in collaboration
with Harvard International Review we answer
all these questions.
We’ll leave you more information in the
links in the description.
So without further ado, let's get started.
(PILLARS IN THE SAND: FROM THE DESERT TO THE
WORLD)
In 1997, Mohamed Alabbar, former Director
General of the Department of Economic Development
of Dubai, was given an assignment: to found
Emaar properties, today one of the most recognized
and most visible brands in all of Dubai.
Its name is everywhere.
And that’s hardly surprising given that,
it is the developer that has carried out the
largest projects in the city: the development
of Downtown, the Burj Khalifa, the Dubai Mall,
Dubai Marina and many of the luxury hotels.
We are talking about a company that has developed
most of the projects that have shaped the
current Dubai.
Practically everything that is characteristic
of this city has been promoted by Emaar.
But who is behind this developer?
Well, as many of you can imagine, the commission
to start up this company came from the government
of the Dubai emirate itself.
The same government that in 2000 listed the
company on the local stock exchange and that
currently still controls almost 30% of a company
that over the years has become a multinational.
Today Emaar has activities in a lot of different
countries, thanks to which it had a net profit
of almost $7 billion in 2022.
But, of course, the company's crown jewel
remains Dubai, a city where projects keep
coming.
One of its latest major projects is precisely
the development of Dubai Creek Harbour, a
huge new district that in the coming years
is sure to become one of the city's major
attractions.
Incidentally, most of the government's participation
is channeled through ICB, the Investment Corporation
of Dubai, the investment muscle of the Dubai
government, which in addition to Emaar, controls
or has investments in many, many other companies.
In fact, the Investment Corporation of Dubai
has had a lot to do with the success of this
city.
So you see, we are talking about an investment
arm of the government that controls assets
worth more than $300 billion dollars.
It owns or has stakes in many of the main
local companies such as the Emirates NBD bank,
the Dubai Islamic Bank, the airlines Emirates
and flyDubai along with the developer Emaar,
which we have already mentioned, as well as
more than 60 companies in which it has total
or partial stakes.
So where does the money they invest come from?
Well, basically from issuing debt, reinvesting
profits and public account surpluses.
But the most interesting thing is that over
the years, the government of Dubai has used
this partnership to promote business in the
city or to cover those areas that are important
for general development.
Yet it did so following a strict market policy.
The companies participating or promoted had
to and have to be competitive not only in
Dubai, but they must be able to compete in
the international market.
This would generate sufficient profits to
enable this vehicle to continue investing
in new projects.
A good example is the case of Emirates.
It is clear that in 1979, when the Dubai World
Trade Center was inaugurated, Dubai had a
clear problem: it was isolated from the world.
Who would want to make a long journey to reach
such an inhospitable place?
However, if you want to become a financial,
tourist and commercial center, you need one
thing: communications.
To solve this problem, in March 1985 the Emirate
of Dubai created Emirates, an airline that
would revolutionize intercontinental air transport
and make this city-emirate one of the best-connected
enclaves on the planet.
It doesn't matter if you want to fly to Tokyo,
Sydney or London.
In Dubai, you always have connections.
To achieve this, in early 1985, the Dubai
government gave British entrepreneur Maurice
Flanagan $10 million and as many administrative
facilities as possible.
His goal?
To launch an airline in five months that had
to perform well and make money.
There would be no subsidies or extra protection.
The company had to fly, excuse the pun, on
its own.
And boy, did it deliver.
Today Emirates is one of the largest and most
profitable airlines in the world.
It operates in 148 airports around the world
and in 2022, despite the industry still reeling
from the effects of the pandemic, it earned
almost $3 billion.
But above all, Emirates has made Dubai one
of the best-connected places in the world.
This has made it easier for workers, entrepreneurs,
investors and, of course, tourists to come
to this city.
Take a look.
(Aug 7, 2023: Dubai welcomes over 8.55mn visitors
in 6 months surpassing pre-pandemic levels
- Arabian Business)
And so, along with special economic zones,
low taxes and legal certainty, Dubai's success
has another key ingredient: the entrepreneurial
spirit of its government.
The key word here is entrepreneurial, not
to create inefficient and elephantine state-owned
companies, but to promote the creation of
companies that, while promoting the local
economy, need to make money and be very competitive,
whatever the cost.
But, that's not even all.
The idea of the entrepreneurial State goes
much further.
In Dubai, the vast majority of projects go
ahead if they are likely to be profitable.
And the government also supports private companies.
For example, one of its latest initiatives
has been to launch a fund of almost $300 million
to encourage 1,000 technology start-ups to
set up in Dubai.
So...
As you can see, we could almost say that this
emirate-city functions more like a company
than a conventional government.
And certainly today its success is undeniable.
Of course, this is not a unique case.
Singapore's success also has a lot in common
with Dubai’s.
Let’s check it out.
(THE CITY OF THE MERLION)
In 1942 the Japanese took control of the British
enclave of Singapore.
It is a strategically located city, which
the British Empire had turned into an important
naval base and which suffered greatly during
the Second World War.
By the end of that war, the city was a disaster:
the damage suffered was enormous, many if
not most infrastructure was destroyed, and
mortality, violence and corruption rates were
sky high.
Singapore was a very poor city where virtually
no one in their right mind would want to live.
And do you know what?
The future didn't look much better.
As it turned out, the Korean War and the global
demand for tin and rubber made things better
and Singapore regained its role as a trading
port.
But little else.
There was even the threat of a communist revolution
in the city.
In 1958 the city achieved full autonomy, and
in 1963, after declaring its definitive independence
from the British Empire, it was integrated
into Malaysia.
However, things did not work out.
In 1965 the Malaysian federation threw Singapore
out.
And so the country would begin its journey
alone...
Which was not particularly optimistic.
Singapore was basically an impoverished island
with no natural resources.
It did not even have enough drinking water
to supply its population.
Water had to be imported from Malaysia.
These days, of course, things are totally
different.
Over the following 60 years, Singapore experienced
an unprecedented boom that has led it to become
the fourth richest country in the world.
A tremendously prosperous place with one of
the highest standards of living on the planet.
Of course, as we have already told you on
VisualPolitik, openness to foreign investment,
a high level of legal certainty, relatively
low taxes and a clear vocation for savings
were key elements.
However, Singapore's success has also had
another ingredient,
As we have seen in the case of Dubai, the
government of Singapore also had a clear entrepreneurial
calling...
In 1974 the Singapore government founded TEMASEK,
a kind of sovereign wealth fund or investment
arm that today manages assets worth almost
$300 billion US dollars.
That is more than US$50,000 per citizen.
The most curious thing, however, is that the
Singapore government created this financial
vehicle to bring together state-owned companies
and to keep politicians and civil servants
away from them.
The idea at that time was that the 35 companies
owned by or receiving participation from the
State would function as true private companies,
even though they still belonged to the State.
That was the beginning, but then with reinvested
profits they started investing in new businesses
to fuel their growth.
Up until 2002, TEMASEK concentrated the vast
majority of its investments in Singapore,
but then they started investing in the rest
of the world, particularly in Asia.
The idea is that these investments in foreign
companies created or strengthened corporate
ties with Singapore itself.
For example, almost a quarter of all their
investments are in China.
As it turned out, over the years, TEMASEK
not only made it possible to professionalize
state-owned companies, but it has also become
a huge piggy bank for the government and has
helped to propel a lot of new companies.
Especially in sectors considered strategic
for the city.
Do you remember what we said about Emirates
before?
Well, something similar happened in Singapore.
TEMASEK is the largest shareholder of Singapore
Airlines, holding 55% of the shares.
With its help, this airline not only connected
Singapore with the rest of the world, but
also became one of the most reputable airlines.
And what is even better, is that it also became
one of the most valuable and profitable airlines
on the planet.
The estimated profit for 2023 is close to
$2 billion US dollars.
And the same could be said of many other companies.
VisualPolitik viewers, with these kinds of
strategies, both Dubai and Singapore achieved
several objectives:
Firstly, they filled some important gaps,
such as communications.
Secondly, they contributed to the professionalization
of state-owned companies.
("One of the tragic illusions that many countries
of the Third World entertain is the notion
that politicians and civil servants can successfully
perform entrepreneurial functions.
It is curious that, in the face of overwhelming
evidence to the contrary, the belief persists."
– Dr Goh Keng Swee, the first Finance Minister
of Singapore)
Thirdly, they helped boost and develop a lot
of economic sectors, which in turn attracted
a lot of foreign companies and professionals.
In other words, by themselves, these investment
arms have driven – and still drive – a
lot of foreign investment.
And lastly, they have created a huge piggy
bank that generates billions of dollars in
profits each year.
And don't forget that we are talking about
two relatively small territories.
Dubai has a population, including all foreign
professionals, of only about 3.5 million people.
Singapore, in contrast, about 5.5 million.
And yet, the numbers we are looking at are
formidable.
Not surprisingly, in addition to creating
these investment arms, both governments opened
their doors wide to foreign companies and
promoted entrepreneurship like there was no
tomorrow.
So, the question we can ask ourselves is,
could this same model be replicated to help
develop much poorer regions?
Would it be possible to create similar cities
in places in Africa or even Latin America?
And remember this is no trivial matter.
For instance, the lack of legal security,
openness and connectivity currently make Miami
the headquarters for the Latin American activities
of more than 1,400 multinationals.
If Latin America were as business-friendly
as Dubai or Singapore, it is quite possible
that the vast majority of these multinationals
would not be in Miami, but in that other city.
On the other hand, while Dubai and Singapore
have built huge piggy banks that have also
promoted economic development, Latin American
commodity-exporting countries have not been
so lucky.
Of course, Venezuela is a textbook example.
We are talking about tens of billions of dollars
that were squandered instead of contributing
to national development.
Be that as it may, at this point it is over
to you: What do you think of the entrepreneurial
governance model of Dubai and Singapore?
Do you think that formulas like these could
be replicated in Latin America or Africa?
Leave us your answer in the comments.
I hope that you found this new partnership
between VisualPolitik and Harvard International
Review as interesting as we did.
If so, don't forget to like and subscribe
to the channel if you haven't already done
so.
Thank you very much for watching.
All the best and see you next time.